(swoosh)
(bounce)
- What's up believe nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of
the world's major problems.
I start the Mentor Me
series with a goal to try to
learn from people who've
done more than us.
And by hanging around
them a little longer,
hopefully some of their
mindsets that are added
to their beliefs, their
confidence, seep into us
to help us to become the
best version of ourselves.
So today, we're going to
learn from John Jocko Willink
and some of his best motivation.
Rule number one is my personal
favorite and I love to know
which one you guys like the best.
And as always guys, as
you're watching the clips,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in quotes
in the comments below.
You might win a prize but
also when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(hopeful music)
(boom)
- Where does discipline
come from?
(slow serious music)
It's pretty simple
and pretty obvious.
Discipline comes from within.
It's an internal force.
Now sure, of course you can
have discipline imposed on you
by some person like a drill instructor
or like that
self-help guru on TV.
But the reality is that type of discipline
isn't the real type of discipline
that we're talking about.
That discipline isn't as
strong, it won't survive.
What you need is self-discipline.
(exciting powerful music)
Now self-discipline comes from the self,
it comes from you.
It comes from when you make a decision
to be disciplined,
when you make a decision to be better,
when you make a decision
to do more and to be more.
Self-discipline comes when you decide
that you're going to
make a mark on the world.
And if you think that
you're not disciplined
or you can't be disciplined, it's because
you haven't yet decided to be disciplined.
It's because you haven't
created that discipline
yet.
(stormy music)
So make the decision, make the commitment.
Discipline, the root
quality that will improve
every aspect of your
life and it'll make you
better and stronger and smarter
and faster and healthier.
And most important,
it'll make you free.
I don't really like those words.
Self-help or self-management
or self-improvement,
I don't really like what those words have
come to mean these days.
Cuz there's a lot of people
out there that are constantly
trying to improve themselves
by looking for the one change,
the one change right, the
one change in their life
that's going to make
their dreams come true.
And even worse, on top of
that, there's a lot of people
out there, a lot of
self-help gurus and these
hyperactive motivational
speakers and these other
self-appointed modern
zen yoga warriors that
they're trying to sell the one
thing, they're trying to sell
the nine steps or the
enlightened path that's going to
allow you to unlock all
of your human potential
and fulfill the dreams
so you can live the life
that you've always wanted to live.
Now, I'm no guru
and I definitely don't claim to be.
I'm just a man.
But I will tell you this.
It isn't one thing and it isn't 10 things
and it isn't a hundred
things, it isn't a quick path
and there are no shortcuts.
And meditation won't get
you there and neither will
a miracle drug or an organic
supplement or some super food.
Getting better isn't a hack or a trick
or a one change that you need to make.
Getting better is a
campaign, it's a campaign,
it's a daily, a weekly,
it's an hourly fight.
An incessant fight that
doesn't stop against weakness
and against temptation
and against laziness.
It's a campaign of discipline.
It's a campaign of hard
work and dedication.
It's waking up early and going to bed late
and grinding out every second in between.
Every single day.
So you want to get better?
You want to self-improve?
Stop looking for a shortcut
and go find your alarm clock
and find your discipline
and find your guts and
your passion and your drive
and find your will.
And then,
and then you will find
your freedom.
Those days when I'm tired or warn out
or just basically sick of the grind,
what do I do on those days?
I go anyways,
I get it done even if
I'm just going through the motions,
I go through the motions.
I don't really want to workout?
I work out.
I really don't want to
hammer on a project?
I hammer on the project.
Don't really want to get
up and get out of bed?
Yeah, I get up and get out of bed.
Now these could be signals
that you need some time off.
And those signals might be right,
they could be correct but
don't take today off, not today.
Wait until tomorrow.
Don't give in to the
immediate gratification
that is whispering in your ear.
Shut that down, do not
listen to that little voice.
Instead, go through the
motions, lift the weights,
sprint the hill, work on the project,
get out of bed.
Now as an overall rule, I
do not like procrastination.
You need to get things done.
But if you are going to rest,
that is one thing that you
should procrastinate on.
That's the one thing I want
you to put off until tomorrow.
And if when tomorrow comes,
you still feel like you need to rest
or you need to take a break,
then okay, take it.
But the chances are you won't.
You won't need that rest.
The chances are you will realize that
the desire to rest was just weakness,
it was just the desire to take
the path of least resistance,
the downhill path, the easy path.
And by simply going through the motions,
you overcame that path and you
stayed on the righteous path,
the disciplined path,
you stayed on the warpath
which is right where you know
that you belong.
So I want to tell you something else
and I want to make this clear.
Don't just listen.
Don't just listen, do.
I'm not just talking, so you know,
I'm not just talking, I'm doing
and I don't want you to just listen.
Put his information to work.
Make today count,
every day.
Go forward, get aggressive and attack
whether it's on the
battlefield or on the beat,
or in the factory or on the farm or on
the construction site or on the website,
in the garage, or in the firehouse,
don't hesitate, step.
Step forward
and get after it.
There's so much knowledge out
there, so much information,
so many ways to get better
and we make,
we make so many mistakes.
We're the product of our mistakes
and often times the
lesson is sitting there
right in front of our face.
It's there to be learned but we miss it
or we don't pay attention to
it or we think we know better
until it punches us in the face.
And the most important
thing to learn is that
we have so much to learn, we all do.
And we can learn from
school and from people
and from experience
and we learn from life.
But you have to process the information,
you have to absorb it,
you have to accept it,
you have to open your mind,
you've got to free your mind
so that you can learn
and make real progress.
And as far as regrets and things I wish
I would have done differently, of course.
Hindsight, hindsight is 20 20
and looking back of course,
who wouldn't want to take
another go at something
and improve on the first
try by doing it again?
And then why not do it
again and again and again
and why not just do it over and over again
until you have it perfect?
But the fact is, you
don't get that chance.
You get one shot, one shot
at this gig right here, life.
One life, that's all you've got.
And regret, in and of itself,
it's worthless, it does nothing for you.
In fact, the only valuable thing in regret
is the lesson you learned.
The knowledge that you gained.
But walking around filled with regret
gets you nothing.
So, learn and move on.
Don't let regret beat you down,
don't be a slave to regret, no.
Let it teach you, let it make you better.
Let the fear of regret fuel you
to take action today, now.
To take action now to become
a better person not filled with regret,
but filled with knowledge.
Filled with knowledge
and strength and power
and filled with life.
Any type of danger right gives you this
flight or fight response, so train.
It starts with training.
Jujitsu, boxing, Muay Thai, wrestling,
shooting, competing, competing right?
You get used to those
butterflies when you compete,
you get those butterflies
and you get used to em.
And so train
and get used to seeing how that reaction,
what that adrenaline feels like
and also get used to understanding
what the superior action is, right?
Fight or flight, cuz sometimes
flight is the correct response.
Sometimes fight is the correct response.
But you want to do is you
want to be able to assess
and dictate which response
you're going to give
and not just do whatever
your instincts tells you
cuz sometimes your
instinct might be wrong.
And so again, I don't know
what you're actually...
The situation where you're going into
but whatever it is, cuz people get
the fight or flight
response to everyday things,
to like public speaking right?
- [Interviewer] Oh yeah.
- Rock climbing
and an answer where I say like you know,
do these things, train in them.
So public speaking,
rock climbing, you know,
if you want to get good at
rock, you want to get over that
fight or flight response when you get...
Go rock climbing, you'll get used to it.
You scared of heights, go
start parachuting you know,
you'll get used to it.
You're scared of the water?
Get worked up and go through swimming
and then you can come scuba certified.
Just, the things that
you're not comfortable with,
get comfortable with being uncomfortable
while you're doing them too.
While you're doing them, pay attention.
You got to detach a little
bit when these things are...
When you're training, detach a little bit
and see what is going on in your mindset,
see what red flags that
you can see, what things
will make you aware of the
fact that you're nerves
or your adrenaline and you feel yourself
clenching your fist, you know
okay so I'm clenching my fist,
be aware of it so that you can change it,
so you can adjust it.
And again, put yourself
into these scenarios
and escalate them so they
get harder and harder
and harder and worse and worse and worse
until you start to get
control of these things.
One of my direct
subordinates, one of my guys
that work for me, he would
call me up or pull me aside
with some major problem,
some issue that was going on
and he'd say, "Boss, we got this and that
"and the other thing."
And I look at him and I'd say, "Good."
(slow piano music)
And finally one day,
he was telling me about some
issue that he was having,
some problem and he said,
"I already know what you're
"going to say," and I said,
"Well what am I going to say?"
He said, "You're going to say good."
He said, "That's what you always say.
"What something is wrong and
going bad, you always just
"look at me and say good."
And I said, "Well yeah."
(heavy rock guitar)
When things are going bad,
there's going to be some good
that's going to come from it.
Didn't get the new high
speed gear we wanted?
Good.
Didn't get promoted, good.
More time to get better.
Oh, mission got canceled?
Good, we can focus on our other one.
Didn't get funded, didn't
get the job you wanted,
got injured, sprained my ankle,
got tapped out, good.
Got beat?
Good, you learned.
Unexpected problems?
Good.
We have the opportunity
to figure out a solution.
That's it, when things are going bad,
don't get all bummed
out, don't get startled,
don't get frustrated
(high pitch electronic echo)
If you can say the word Good,
guess what, it means you're still alive.
It means you're still breathing.
And if you're still breathing?
For now, you still got
some fight left in you.
So get up, dust off, reload,
recalibrate, reengage
and go out on the attack.
(slow piano music)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did you think,
what did you take from this
video that you're going to
immediate apply somehow to
your life or to your business?
Let me know down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Brandon
from OnePercentBetter,
thank you so much Brandon
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word
and doing that awesome YouTube
review on your channel.
I really appreciate the support man
and I'm glad you enjoyed my book.
- We are happy to have you on the channel.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
(swoosh)
(bounce)